from fox 4
new proposal would give id cards to
illegal immigrants could be used for air
travel so i decided to uh
research some basic definitions
do you know what a country is defined as
anybody know what a country is defined
as
a country yes
um how do you define the word country i
can give what i think is a definition it
might not match up exactly let's hear it
um i would say
an
area or region
with a
some degree of juris jurisdiction
over it
and
board has to have a border who the
region has jurisdiction it's like a rock
monster owns the land that it is
yeah i would say okay a a piece of land
or a region with a border it's got some
geographical and you need one more
component capacity
and then
some type of governance structure people
people a country is defined as a nation
with set borders
okay and a nation is a group of people
with a shared history and set of laws
history culture or set of laws okay so
when you combine that you have nation
and country they're not the same thing
the united states is a country okay it
is a nation with borders so when we have
a wave of mil a million plus illegal
immigrants entering the country
then you have no country if the borders
can't be enforced so the latin for
country is against or opposite
and then the other part of it from the
medieval latin is against a lying
opposite land so you're literally in
opposition to the other land that is
close to you so when you have a million
people under the borders and there's
nothing being done about it when you
have the government facilitating the
trafficking of children which the bond
administration has been doing in the
dead of night secretly
there's no borders no you have no
country now about that nation yes a
shared history well you don't have a
shared history with people coming from
other nations entering in violation of
your laws so there's no shared history
and there's no shared laws and there's
no shared culture there is no nation
there is no country
giving id cards to illegal immigrants
that could be used for air travel
this is just creating open citizenship
why do you think they're doing this
again this is destroying the united
states yeah exactly exactly this is true
to me this is the controlled demolition
again because it's like well
why why why would you do that let me let
me let me let me simplify real quick uh
for you for everybody at home zubi let's
say you have a big um
granary let's say you have a big storage
facility full of food and your guards
open the doors and say everybody come on
in and you're like but that's where i
keep all my stuff and they're like bigot
yeah so uh
look this country is wealthy but you
can't just have an endless flow of
people coming in
even bernie sanders said the exact same
thing at a rally in 2015. he said you
know heavens
if we open the borders we'd be flooded
by the world's poor we can't do that
yeah back when bernie cared about the
working class i guess
i think that people believe
uh that the avalanche only flows one
direction and so they're just getting on
board they're trying to surf the wave
they're like nationalism is done
globalism is now one earthen country and
let's just do it it's not possible
yeah it doesn't seem it's gonna be
abrupt and a lot of people will get hurt
in the process but like it's just a
world government duh people will
definitely seem to want that we are
going to call it the liberal
international economy by the way that's
l-i-e for from here on out yeah that
that is yes the lie so um when you go to
egypt for instance yeah you're egyptians
aren't allowed to gamble or eat pork
like by government law yeah so how are
we supposed to have a one-world
government when it's like we're gonna
get a big shipment of pork in for our
bacon and then a bunch of other
countries are like no no no no our tax
dollars can't go to that you're not
allowed to do that
this is essentially what they're trying
to do making entertainment into
something global yeah it doesn't work
you know what global entertainment is
not even a common language like you
can't even communicate properly with
most people in the world let me let me
tell you guys there's a you ever see the
just for laugh gags no oh i think so
they're like those youtube videos where
there's one where it's really funny a
little girl she has four buckets one's
two of them are full complete with
change then two of them have a false top
with change on top
and so she walks over or she has she
like waves someone over
and then she asks them for help caring
she grabs the fake light buckets it's
like a little girl and she carries them
and the other people try to lift the
heavy things full of change they can't
do it they're like like how is this
little girl carrying this there's no
dialogue at all just music this was
entertainment made for a global audience
not a word being said
so when you want to create global
entertainment no dialogue that's how the
trailer for avatar
was the second avatar movie all just
like
b-roll of cgi oceans and aliens and
jungles and like
ambient music and i'm like what am i
watching right now what is the story
there's none
yeah yeah i'm not worried about one
world cup
that one's not going to happen i mean no
i think it will happen just not i think
it'll happen yeah i think it's an
inevitability i think it's impossible to
avoid how so why do you think that so
technological advancement the rapid
rapid communications development is
going to result in a global shared
culture just not anytime soon
um soon as
by soon i mean like five to ten years
but you give it a couple generations
especially with uh
if we have air travel then i think
it's possible to have one world
government through cultural expansion
but they're also shutting down uh
air travel but they're also creating
metaverse and virtual reality
so already i used to play video games
with people in oceania and china and
japan like world of warcraft for
instance
those people are friends they have
cultural bonds stronger than their next
door neighbors
that's the kind of thing that
precipitates one world government that's
right i don't think most people are
going to have any remote interest in
that
it's it's not about whether or not
what is
i i don't think you're not going to get
majority of the world onto vr and the
metaverse and all that i don't think
it's i don't think so i i think you will
i don't know if it'll be the iteration
that we're seeing now but bro we're
already there you live on twitter that's
your virtual person i'm not normal
like you'll get some people you there's
eight billion plus people in this world
and most people live in lives nothing
like what and what what did mark
zuckerberg google and starlink what have
they been and elon musk what have they
been trying to do over the past 10 years
they're trying to connect people in
various ways
where they were like can we get internet
to you know
like the middle of africa with giant
balloons floating in the stratosphere
broadcasting we've got low orbit
satellite technology they know they need
to wire all of these people that's what
i'm saying once you get everybody on the
internet and there's such luxury that
comes with being online such advantage
that's what precipitates the expansion i
think you'll get everyone on the
internet i don't think you're gonna get
everyone running around in in headsets
or sitting there well that's that's like
saying i can't imagine everyone's gonna
put a vinyl record player in their home
or like it's joe biden saying i think i
think these are really different i think
they're quite different when we get to
the point where your neurolink implant
is put in at birth and you have a say in
the matter yeah we'll get there
what makes you
why be so pessimistic in that i assume
you think this is a bad thing it's not
pessimism do you think do you think
that's a bad thing
uh i think it's an it's a neutral thing
i think people uh
yeah i think it's a relatively neutral
thing i don't i think technology is not
good or bad i do i do i do think it
leans toward the bad because we know
corrupt people will exploit all of this
for for personal gain and we could
potentially end up in an equilibrium
type future where
everyone has their emotions and thoughts
suppressed and the global leaders live
freely and enjoy the perks of being
human yeah but but ultimately look look
what twitter has done look what facebook
and youtube have become the rapid
expansion of social media in only 10
years people are going online and
they're already existing with a digital
version of themselves and it's only
expanded more and more maybe mark
zuckerberg's mark zuckerberg's legless
metaverse is not going to be the version
of wire that everyone gets into
but already
aoc for instance is not representing new
york's 14 she's representing progressive
twitter sure she gets money because
one person in every city
may have a fringe world view but
together online they make up a massive
powerful economic block
they support someone like aoc and then
she wins her ideas are unpopular and
wouldn't have won
but because
all of the weird fringe far left people
were able to raise money online
so that created something that exists
outside of a nation i saw this back
going to 2010 and we've seen it
further look at ukraine look at look at
warfare over the past 10 years when you
have individual actors joining nation
states in conflict when hackers in the
united states were aiding in the
revolutions in north africa and the
middle east this is this is global
government when you have u.s citizens
teaming up with a whole with a network
of citizens and then going and fighting
in ukraine this is global government it
is the precursor it's common
i don't think so i think we'll see we
need one why don't we need it but one
language you'd mentioned earlier that
everybody speaks one language i thought
close to it it would be english just
because of capitalism and the way
corporatism and is putting mcdonald's
all over the place and people watch
hollywood movies i thought for sure the
whole world will be speaking english
it'll be considered like common in dnd
but i don't know if that's the case now
oh no i'll be mandarin we need to get
internet to everybody and fresh water to
everybody and then why in order for a
global internet away
i kind of do because i think the other
option is self-destruction if we don't
connect we're gonna destroy we'll fight
unless we're together
unified is the internet togetherness
it's a form in any way sure like what
we're doing right now there's like 50
000 people watching live or something
like that it's intense unity i disagree
that that's a community though yeah not
everyone needs to be unified for for
there not to be
uh severe conflict you can't unify
everybody like people are just too
freaking different but not necessarily
like we all have to do the same thing
but that we all have some sort of common
purpose or ideal i mean we do as human
beings i mean i think that's always
existed um but past a certain level um
people people are are too different and
people have such different interests and
you you travel around the world go to
different countries
they're not all i guess people need
conflict yeah and they're not all
joining now they don't need it it's hard
enough
it's hard enough to reunite conflict
resolution it's hard to unite the usa
let alone the world one one one proposed
hypothesis i'm not a an evolutionary
biologist psychologist or anthropo
anthropologist but why is it that europe
had advanced more than the americas why
did the native american populations
man did they go on nitro when they
started coffee into their proximity
the the european tribes were roman roads
they were boxed in a peninsula with with
very little uh room to flee to
so when resources would become strained
they'd kill each other to survive
causing a a tit-for-tat expansion of
technologies in order to survive in the
americas it was so vast the tribes would
just leave
so if you look at animals for instance
badgers why are they so vicious they're
burrowing animals they have one
dimension when they're confronted with
an attacker at the front of their of
their burrow they can either fight or
they can die so of course natural
selection
predicted that they'd be vicious birds
why don't birds attack you why do they
run away because they have multiple
dimensions they have three dimensions
you go up and leave so they're much less
likely to to require conflict more
likely to survive if you escape the
battle
in europe you had humans nowhere to
escape to it's a peninsula
so in these in certain parts it's like
fight or don't and in the americas it's
like yo i got everywhere else to be so
i'm not going to fight you if i don't
have to
when when two different groups of people
are fighting next to each other for a
long period of time they're constantly
one-upping each other it's it's an
artificial uh evolutionary conflict
happening technologically
so
if humans today
stopped fighting
and there was no conflict what would
they do
play video games all day
watch porn all day and this is what
we're starting to see there's no
conflict so what do people do it's
wall-e
get fat sit in their lounge chairs and
complain and just want free stuff to be
pleasured and gratified
that's what happens yeah one thing i've
been thinking about a lot recently
especially um
when it comes to you know children now
or the next generation and so on is
you know i think every everyone
understands and realizes that as human
beings as individuals and even as a
wider society
you need conflict and struggle
and hardship in order to
develop a
resilience right develop grit resilience
a stronger personality ability to
withstand stuff
um and i think so many of the problems
that we have right now when we're
dealing with in the west as tim's
alluded to already is just
just people are weak people are fragile
emotionally oh my gosh you misgendered
me like like the whole world it's all
based in weakness it's based in
victimology you know nerf the world
instead of making yourself stronger
that's really been the attitude for
quite a while now and i often wonder how
is that if there is a way maybe the
answer is no but is there a way to
rather
without having
taking people through this certain grind
of hardship is there a way to
consistently
say raise
strong
minded and even physically strong
children
without
you know who aren't just going to grow
up to be these these lame snowflakes or
whatever you want to call them
without having to go through necessarily
all the same nonsense that their parents
or ancestors did there's a viral pose
it's hilarious where someone some antifa
person is like you better believe the
right is arming up in training and you
better be as equally trained and armed
as they are for the coming conflict and
what do you think the left's response
was to that
uh when we say the left who we leftists
etc
um what was their response to someone on
the left saying you need to start
training and get ready for a conflict
with the right you can't tell me what to
do no i don't know
some of us aren't physically capable
your tweet is ableist
and then they apologize saying we
understand that not everyone is able to
physically train and there are other
ways to help
that's amazing a lot of them just ended
up saying man i'm just so depressed it's
fine
was this on twitter yep one guy was like
yo i'm depressed just use me as a human
shield oh wow
you know what i know why they're
depressed too yeah jordan peterson man
he killed it he he's he's
well the the the the depression he's
killing it you know he's saving young
people in general if they just listen to
him yo people are depressed because they
have no purpose they have no drive no no
no no internal conflict no
responsibility they're just sitting
around staying at the tv like what for
yeah yeah you you have to i mean one
thing i know for for my myself right
because i'm not even gonna i'm not
sitting here pretending oh i came from
some rough background or whatever like
i'm blessed like i'm super privileged in
many regards but i i've had i've created
my own hardship in many ways right like
there are ways that
you know in terms of your whether it's
your career or i mean what what even is
going to the gym going to the gym is
going and
artificially
creating artificially creating
resistance whether to to build your lung
capacity or improve your cardiovascular
system or increase your muscles
like our ancestors would be like what on
earth are what what's what's everyone in
this room doing why don't you just do
your farm work or do your work
i was talking about this recently we had
uh we we purchased like
wild caught salmon or whatever yeah and
i was like so people in the us who have
money can order fresh fish
lower to middle class people get garbage
farm fish and then third world poor
people eat fresh fish
and so the funny thing is like
we have a lake out here you're allowed
to fish but you got to throw the fish
back okay and i was like that's the
stupidest thing i ever heard not not i
understand we gotta throw the fish back
i'm just like why go fishing for no
reason it's like people like simulating
survival exactly
dude that's what it all is why are
people so drawn to sport yeah right like
so many of the things that we do when we
find impressive it's like
you're
making your life harder than it needs to
be you're you're creating the artificial
um pressures and and why are so many
people now getting into mma and combat
sports and stuff like that's because
you need to
you're not going to get it in your
day-to-day life right you don't need to
do anything i say we do away with war we
place it we we replace it with the
sporting event
soccer maybe i don't know
football have the olympia football or
soccer yeah well that'll be whoever wins
gets to name it so it certainly helps i
also by the way i think this is part of
why why so many people snapped in 2020
because all the usual outlets
for for for energy and and tension and
even just the the social
it was just allowed to pile up
zooby where is everybody
where's everybody so we got a pilot
shortage right
we have like medical worker shortages
we've got we've got labor shortages
across the board and they fire a bunch
of people last year but how do people
just stop working where does that food
come from
um food is very easy to acquire
but oh oh sorry you mean if these people
stop working how are they paying their
rent
um well they sorry wait let let's okay
so we're going to
rewind this okay airlines are shutting
down thousands of flights okay i wasn't
always aware of that yeah pilot shortage
is this specifically in the usa all over
i think it's all over the world okay i
mean it's heavily in the u.s i follow us
news but uh pilot shortage and i'm like
where did those pilots go did they just
stop working and if they did how are
they paying their bills how are they
buying food but it's not just that you
go to fast food restaurants and they've
got signs in the door saying like we're
understaffed i've seen that every all
over the place
we went out on memorial day weekend not
nobody
i'm like where where are the people at
where'd they all go
where are the workers how is it that
people stopped working
and didn't start working again i don't
understand like uh you're a pilot you
weren't gonna do go be a mailman why
would you do that you're a pilot
i don't know i'm not i'm not familiar
with the pilot thing at all generally
speaking yeah how is there a shortage of
these jobs
are they just choosing not to hire them
back or something but where is everybody
else how has the people stopped working
and they're not working now where's
their food coming from where they where
where they're how are they paying
utilities how they paying rent or
mortgages
i don't know i am not i'm not super
familiar with this issue so i don't i
don't really know what's been happening
i'm concerned that there's a black
market evolving that people don't know
about and i'm really concerned that
people great amazing humans that got
screwed over by the last two years worth
of mandates and whatever running out of
money are gonna turn to nefarious things
to get by like
human trafficking and things like that
i
man
i i i'd be cautious of
predicting something that dark yeah i
just want to get it on the table now so
in 10 years you guys remember i said it
first i to put nothing past anyone in
desperate times
i made the joke to uh sheamus that the
rapture happened
and then he was like well certainly it
couldn't have you know because he's
devout catholic so it's like hey wait a
minute you know what are you saying
but uh no man look we
i mean obviously i see people out doing
stuff we went played pool the other day
and had wings good fun a lot of people
out there playing pool on a weekend
but
when you hear about all these labor
shortages and when i go to
uh like a like a chipotle and they're
like we're understaffed please bear with
us i'm like how is it possible that
people just aren't working there there
is a lot of laziness as well and again
inertia i get it but like how do they
how are they getting by but hasn't this
always been a question i mean there are
lots of there's millions and millions
and millions of people who don't work
and haven't been working for
a long time and they somehow get but i
don't know if it's just welfare or if
it's i don't even know what all the
schemes and stuff like that are um i
just work you know we just work but
there are millions of people in this
country in any country who don't work
but they're alive
yeah i suppose i don't know exactly what
they do have we expanded the welfare
state to such a point that we can have
labor shortages and keep giving them
money maybe i i honestly have no idea
what the welfare structure
looks like here how much more money is
being spent now than was
two or three years ago i have no idea
what any of that looks like so they say
that the poor people in the u.s rival
some of the richer people in europe
because our welfare system is increasing
like deep there's a lot of layers to it
so i think that might be where they're
all going i think that over the course
of the pandemic they realized oh my gosh
i don't really have to work i'm not
essential right i can work from home
people have pointed out retirement but
that doesn't explain fast food
restaurants that doesn't explain yogurt
shops and burger burger joints i know
retirement is one of the ones for pilots
because i did see something saying that
they're not training up enough new
pilots they're raising the age
oh really wow
yeah so quit yeah so there aren't there
aren't enough people being incentivized
to become pilots to compensate for the
older ones
what bothers me the us government
printed all that money in the last two
years and then just started handing it
out to people you're making you're
sending people towards bankruptcy and
then they're gonna stop paying their
taxes because they can't afford to
survive you fools and then if they're
not then you're gonna have a revolution
on your hands
like the the the usa maybe the usa such
as it's it's such a fascinating country
because one thing that americans always
always forget is how how young this
country is i always say that the usa is
a teenager
as far as countries go and also it's
it's a giant teenager with 50
states an angry teenager
with a desert eagle yeah
like there's so many things that are
unique about the usa that make it
genuinely impossible to
properly compare to
any other country in the world it's got
so many things that are absolutely
unique i mean even if someone said oh
let's well let's compare it to all of
europe
it's like that's maybe that's a better
comparison than to one country in europe
but it's also it's it's so
so different abusive father you know
king george just beat the hell out of
him
i got this angry rage from our
childhood yeah we we had to emancipate
ourselves yeah we had to run away from
home like at age 12 it was crazy sibling
is still up there
acting all wacky and elitist
i love it the left has this meme where
they're like the united states canada
must feel like they've got like a
dysfunctional sibling who's you know
walking around with guns and i'm like
who's the size of a toddler maybe
i kind of think it's like you know
canada is the snooty frail you know
sibling who is the aunt karen canada
didn't run away from home like america
did no but we were the children of of
you know the crown and so canada was
like why are you fighting just do what
father says
and we were like no
honestly every time i look at a map or a
globe i'm always like like i look at the
the geographical size of the uk or great
britain even which is even smaller and
i'm just like
how out
physics it's like the size of new jersey
isaac newton isaac newton developed
physics so england got the cannons first
and then they could hit long range with
their boats so they dominated the world
yeah conquered india yeah i know i i
know how it happens i just look at the
size of the country it's amazing what
technology can do for a small cut like a
piece of attack that nuclear power is
kind of like that nuclear weaponry like
israel is heavily armed right now
they're massively influential on the
world stage well we give them money so
they can build weapons
yes
there you go
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 p.m eastern time
super chat will even answer some of your
questions if you want to check out the
after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you